[Music]
normally people die understand and grace
I'm not so sure
Wednesday's collecting monsters look for
someone you don't let's see your face
gotten a shadow
do not say anything we don't get out of
here soon they'll be carrying out
cultures new American gods this is going
to be episode 4 Easter eggs and the
episode 5 trailer I'll start with
episode 4 then I'll do episode 5 stuff
so just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet obviously the big
WTF is all the laura stuff they explain
the backstory you get the reveal that
she was the one that saved shadow and
she's got superpowers now that she's
dead she's almost more alive now that
she's dead like she has a purpose and
her purpose is shadow and for those of
you asking how she came back to life
it's because of shadows coin the Sun
remember it was either episode 2 or
episode 3 where we learn from the
sisters when she gives him the moon you
used to have a better charm the Sun this
isn't quite as good but it'll still help
protect you so the Sun coin is Aztec
gold it represents the Sun the Hermetic
Sun of alchemy which turned things into
gold but it's also effectively the
Philosopher's Stone which gives life so
you know everybody's a Harry Potter fan
the Philosopher's Stone all about trying
to bring Voldemort back to life when the
coin touches her she becomes a revenant
but the day difference in the books is
that she doesn't have superpowers she's
just kind of like a normal person only
she doesn't have any bodily fluids she
just walks around like a normal zombie
but that is why mad Sweeney goes so nuts
when he learns he was so drunk he gave
away the wrong coin he didn't do that on
purpose so in the books she walks around
with the coin around her neck on a chain
as long as she keeps the coin she can
continue being the way she is now the
minute she loses it she's done the TV
show hasn't made that very clear because
it seems like the coin is gone now like
once it granted her her life back she's
good but in the books there's just a
little bit more temporary so there were
liberal book changes mr ibis the person
that we've seen writing in the journal
at the beginning of most of the episodes
but coming to America stories that each
of the Gods tell how did they get here
where did they come from and you get a
much bigger look at their funeral parlor
so obviously they say they've been there
for about 200 years in the book what
happened is as you learn about this
place much later in the story and it's
really shadow that's learning
about it they explained that Egyptian
traders came up the Mississippi looking
to trade with people thousands of years
ago thousands of years before people are
known to have discovered America
so shadows chuckling to himself when
he's talking to that like wait a minute
you're telling me that people from all
the way around the world came to America
way before these Vikings that we saw in
the first episode so even in the first
episode you hear about the Vikings that
come you get that big action set piece
where you learn about how they sacrifice
to Odin how gods gain their power and
then a hundred years later the Viking
that we know to have visited America
actually visited it so they're just
trying to tell you that people had been
coming to America for thousands of years
before we ever knew about it Neil Gaiman
did a lot of research when it came to
these parts of the book so you get these
fascinating history lessons that
question your beliefs just like shadow
is having his beliefs question he
doesn't really believe in things that he
can't see in touch but over the course
of the series that's slowly changing so
what they're doing is they're taking a
lot of character interactions a lot of
dialogue and a lot of scenes from later
in the book and bringing it way forward
but in the book there's no Laura moon
chapter so most of what you saw in this
episode is them just expanding on
Laura's story sort of filling in a lot
of the blanks she's not that big of a
character in the books you just know
that she really loves shadow a lot of
the dialogue that she has when she's
talking to shadow after she comes back
that's right out of the book but all
this stuff her back in the casino none
of that was in the book so expect them
to do this when they get to season 2
especially when they get to Samantha
black crow I'm really excited about that
she's a character from the book that we
probably won't see till season 2 at the
rate that they're going they're actually
going very slowly but I love Emily
Browning's performance I totally do not
like her friend but I think that's part
of the point she's meant to be a bit of
an insufferable character in mr. jackal
Anubis is just so amazing if you didn't
know in real life he's actually going to
be the main Klingon on the new Star Trek
TV show so this is mr. Anubis just in
very different makeup really the whole
point of the episode was just to make
Laura more of a character so it didn't
really move the plot forward but it
filled in a lot of really important
backstory so you get more context for
why it is she acts the way that she does
when you're reading her
dialogue in the book she actually sounds
like she's a dead person even when she
was alive
so that really WTF scene with the hot
tub where it looked like she was trying
to end herself that's not from the book
they're just trying to make her seem
really messed up like she was dead until
she was dead then she found purpose and
her purpose is shadow so next week's
episode Episode five is called
lemon-scented you that's the trailer so
obviously it's just focusing on the
reunion in that motel room hey shadow I
was dead now I'm alive surprise but you
see mr. Wednesday and shadow get
captured by the opposition you hear the
technical boy and you see mr. world for
the first time so very very important
character mr. world is the leader of the
Opposition of all the new gods so you
here Wednesday hyping him up in the
books mr. Wednesday wasn't there
shadow was captured from a big party a
big gathering of old gods that mr.
Wednesday had assembled it was taken to
a train car by himself we haven't seen
this big gathering of gods yet mr.
Wednesday hasn't called like a great
council to bring people together and
make his case look we need to join the
fight against the new gods so just
another example of them taking a scene
for way further ahead in the book and
bringing it forward but you can kind of
see what's going on there are eight
episodes next week is going to be
episode five so we're getting pretty
close to the end but it's all about
shadow opening his mind to bigger things
like the idea that the dead can come
back to life the whole thing last week
about him having the ability to create
snow he doesn't completely believe it
yet but he's slowly opening his mind to
that but if you are wondering yes that
was him he does have magical powers I
talked a little bit about his character
in the first episode in the trailer
video I did so I'll link those at the
end of this but at the rate they're
going I have a feeling they'll reach the
house on the rock by the finale that
might be where they end the season with
like a big cliffhanger with mr.
Wednesday making his case so we can
start making our predictions if you have
read the book let me know where you
think they're going to end the first
season but overall this was actually
probably the best episode so far even
though it had absolutely nothing to do
with stuff to happen in the folks there
were a couple moments like you talked to
mr. ibis you go to their funeral parlor
but like 90% of the stuff that happened
is stuff that they made up just to fill
in Laura's backstory but it totally
worked just because it was centered on
those two
characters their journey they were
acting in a very authentic way one of
the biggest complaints that I've seen
against shadow is that he isn't reacting
in a natural way that you would expect
someone to all this crazy stuff
happening around him a normal person
would probably be screaming if he saw
coins being pulled out of thin air even
if he was super drunk but the way you
see him acting on the TV show that's
kind of the way he is in the books he's
very opaque in there giving Ricky
Whittle the actor a lot more dialogue
than book shadow gets he's not very
verbose and there's a lot of internal
model logging so there been a lot of
changes but I feel like most of them
have been for the better so if you're a
big book reader let me know what you
think of the show so far and all the
changes that they've made most of you
American Gods fans are also probably
watching the Twin Peaks premiere they
have like the first four episodes
available I think on the on-demand app
so you can actually watch that that
first four hours if you want or right
now I'm not planning on doing any videos
I might do a Twin Peaks video after the
season is over but it seems like there
are so few people that get those cable
channels because Twin Peaks is Showtime
this is stars that it just doesn't make
a lot of sense for me to do a whole
bunch of videos for that so eventually I
will probably do at least one Twin Peaks
video just depending on how the schedule
works out and how everyone likes them
I'll keep doing American Gods weekly
videos but really next week for American
Gods is a heavy plot episode unlike this
episode which is mostly just backstory
but whole bunch of comic-book stuff
happening this week I'm seeing Wonder
Woman in a couple of days so I'll post a
non-spoilery review so far it seems like
everybody is really digging it but
there's a bunch of finales so while you
wait for all that you can click here for
all my American Gods videos and you can
click here for brand new Game of Thrones
really close for the trailer on that too
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you